hey we're here at the San Francisco
Tennis Club with the winner of the
national memory championships of the
United States
Chester Santos he's gonna teach us some
tips and tricks on how you can improve
your memory for random words and numbers
including techniques known as the body
list and the journey hey Chester I want
you to show up your memory skills but
first why are we at the San Francisco
Tennis Club we're at the San Francisco
Tennis Club because I use the Tennis
Club and portions of it as different
mental journeys I have about three
different journeys that I walk through
within the Tennis Club and I use those
journeys to remind me of what I want to
remember i link images that are
associated with the material that I want
to remember I linked those images to
locations within the Tennis Club in my
mind so Chester you've had about three
minutes to look at these cards it looks
like it's maybe about 20-25 cards and
you think you've got to memorize all
right so here we go I'm gonna you're
gonna call this card and I'm gonna flip
it over alright three diamonds ten of
clubs two of clubs ten of Hearts Queen
of Spades seven of diamonds ten of
diamonds King of Hearts Jack of Clubs
got it
two of spades
Ace of Hearts Ace of Spades 2 of
diamonds clean of heart six of hearts
nine of spades seven of clubs five of
hearts
seven of Spades Ace of Diamonds seven of
Hearts six of spades
eight of clubs one and jack of spades ah
you did it so what I've done here is
I've written down ten random words and
I'm going to give you one minute to
memorize them with no help no with no
strategy no strategy and we'll see how
many you can get in the correct order
okay Apple watch
umbrella stapler car so you got up to
the third word alright go to the third
word that's not bad
okay so what I'm gonna do now is I'm
going to guide you through this list in
about one or two minutes okay so I want
you to do is with your left imagine that
with your left foot okay
your left foot you're smashing a giant
Apple into a bunch of applesauce okay
okay smashing it and it's smashing out
from the applesauce okay okay now on
your right foot you have a watch a
wristwatch
wrapped around your right foot okay and
you can hear the loud ticking I want you
to imagine can hearing the loud taping
and all of a sudden an alarm goes off on
the watch all right okay all right
imagine that okay now imagine that catch
to your knees is an umbrella all right
and you push on the button you push on
the button and the umbrella opens up and
it splashes all this water all over your
face okay next you have a tennis racket
lodged into the side of your waist okay
okay now you hear a noise coming from
inside of your belly button okay uh-huh
it's like yeah it's an engine and this
racecar just shoots out of your belly
button and you can see the tire spinning
okay alright alright then you have a
giant basketball okay and it keeps on
hitting you in your chest just that's
giant boom boom shots not hitting you
and your chest okay then now what you
have attached to your neck
you have no reason why but your feeling
here and there's something there and
you're pulling at it in it and it kind
of comes out and you said it's a desk oh
my god was a desk
I don't need a desk here why are cats at
what's it doing that now you you feel a
pain in your mouth I'm feel pain in your
mouth uh-huh
you open up your mouth and there's an
earring in your tongue then next I want
you to imagine that a stapler is
stapling your nose together both the
nostrils are stapled together okay
stapler okay stapler is continually
stapling them and then on the top of
your head you have a you have a giant
comb and you're combing your hair and as
you're combing your hair you don't
something's wrong with this something's
wrong with a comb because as you're
combing your hair a bunch of hair is
getting pulled out of here okay okay all
right I actually think you could see all
that in your mind right yeah I think
I've got it so here we go the first word
is Apple the second word is watch the
third word is umbrella the fourth word
is racket the fifth word is car the next
word is ball the next word is desk the
word after that is earring stapler and
the last one is comb you got it there it
is all ten in a row you got it great job
perfect that was awesome perfect that
works we just did some mental athletic
training with it Chester Santos has the
best memory in the United States some of
his techniques stretch all the way back
to the ancient Greeks but what's amazing
is it standing in front of you as a
modern human being I can still feel
those techniques reprogramming my brain
to remember the
that